all right joining us now with more the
author of the bestseller unwoke how to
defeat cultural Marxism in America
amazon.com bookstores all around the
country am I understanding a bestseller
is that true Senator uh that that's
right two weeks in a row we're we're at
the top of the bestseller list and it
makes a great great Christmas gift so go
go buy it for your friends and loved
ones they'll enjoy it it's fun and it
and and and it's interesting L out a
battle plan for taking the country back
it really does it really was well
written uh I urge people that be a good
Christmas gift for people let me ask you
this Senator let's get your reaction to
Biden you know yeah
apologizing on the issue of not taking
these numbers from Hamas why why would
he be apologizing to anybody for
that well look it's important to
understand Joe Biden has been the most
anti-israel president the United States
has ever had from the very beginning of
the Biden Administration this
Administration has undermined the
government of Israel at every step
they've done so systematically they've
done so at a granular level he is
surrounded by radical anti-israel
activist in his administration his lead
negotiator on Iran Rob Mali who's been
fired had his security clearance revoked
because presumably of violations sharing
Secrets somehow with Iran he his top
three advisers or three of his top three
advisers were Iranian operatives working
for the Iranian foreign Ministry working
essentially as spies on behalf of the
government of Iran undermining the US
government since October 7th since the
October 7th attack began the Biden
administration at every stage has worked
to undermine Israel the as the attack
was happening on the night of October
7th the state department tweeted out a
call for Israel not to engage in
retaliation saying violence never solves
anything they did that in 3 at the
morning 3 in the morning I responded
said this was disgraceful whoever wrote
this tweet should be fired within
minutes they deleted the Tweet the next
day Tony blinkin the Secretary of State
sent another tweet saying it just spoken
with the Turkish foreign minister and
Israel should engage in an immediate
ceasefire again I blasted it online said
this was disgraceful again they deleted
it since then Joe Biden has flown to
Israel urged Israel do not retaliate
against Hamas since then Tony blinkin
has flown to Israel urged Israel do not
retaliate against Hamas at every stage
they are pushing for Israel not to
eradicate amas for for Israel to engage
in a ceasefire for Israel to engage in a
pause and the amazing thing is
Sean as much as the Biden Administration
has undermined Israel the radical left
is protesting Biden saying you're not
pro Hamas enough because that today is
the state of the Democrat Party they
have a viciously anti-semitic radical
left that is pounding this white house
for not doing even more to hurt the
state of Israel let me ask you the
question that I was asking uh secretary
Pompeo uh
earlier Senator I think you and I
probably feel the same way on this I'm
imagining we do uh I don't like this
deal I don't like a ceasefire I don't
like the idea that three prisoners are
given in exchange for innocent children
however I know in my heart and I know
what I think in your heart that if that
was the deal that was taken and it would
result in the release of innocent
citizens in Israel getting released and
even innocent Americans I probably want
to take that deal how do you feel
because I'm I'm conflicted about I I I
I'm conflicted on this and this deal was
was extracted in a horrible situation 58
hostages have now been released and I
will say first of all praise God we have
reason to give celebration and thank God
that 58 hostages women little children
have been released that is a wonderful
thing I'll tell
I've sat Sean in my office with with the
families of of hostages I've heard the
horrible stories of of people who AOSS
terrorists brutalized and and and listen
when it comes to this deal I understand
why Israel entered into it I think prime
minister N yahu I think he is truly an
historic figure I know him well you know
him well I I think he appreciates the
weight of history on his on his
shoulders and he made this deal this
deal has multiple negative consequences
one of the consequences in is in
exchange for these hostages being
released Israel has released roughly
150 Palestinians some significant number
of those were involved in in terrorism
and likely will return to terrorism so
they are releasing people who will try
to kill more innocent civilians secondly
this pause the pause in in the military
attack on Gaza means Hamas has time to
rebuild they're allowing roughly 300
trucks a day to come in from Egypt eypt
with Aid including fuel that fuel is
restocking Hamas the consequence of this
is Hamas will be more difficult to
defeat that both of those are serious
negative consequences of this deal that
being said the Israeli War cabinet voted
to approve this deal and I understand
why bringing those hostages home I is a
major accomplishment and and and I think
it's critical as we bring those hostages
home that we do not allow this to become
fuel for leftists and the Biden
Administration to Pummel Israel and say
do not return to the task of eliminating
Hamas the government of Israel has said
they're going to utterly eradicate Hamas
and if and when they do so that will be
good for Israel that will be good for
America that will be good for the world
and and we need to when the hostages
have come home we need to return to the
task of eliminating these monsters that
committed these atrocities that has to
happen do you agree with my assessment
that Gaza Lebanon and Iran have to all
be dealt with and the territ tels of
course
eliminated yes yes yes and and look
Hamas is the first priority because
Hamas committed these these horrific
atrocities and and let me stop and say
all right so tomorrow morning I'm going
to the Senate I'm doing something I'm
really not looking forward to which is
I'm going to watch about an hour of
footage that the Israeli government has
put together of the atrocities these
terrorist have committed I'm going to
see tragically terrorists raping young
women raping children murdering children
I I I've seen little Snippets of it and
makes you physically sick we know these
terrorists they literally put babies in
ovens and raped their mothers while they
cook the babies alive this is evil and
we've got to stop it but it's nearly a
50-minute video and then they wanted to
Chronicle all of all of those atrocities
you know that that is you know like
Germany in our time I wish I had more
time important the truth be known I'll
put up your book uh congratulations on
it being a bestseller hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else